欢迎来到独跑自由
今天要分享的这本书
《巨人思维 作者是巨人杰》
之所以选这本书
是因为最近财经圈很热闹
周冠然教授和巨人杰
在网路上有一些观点交锋
让更多人开始重新思考
交易到底该怎么看
怎么做
才有机会长期走下去
作者本身很年轻
背景偏理工
偏数据派
而我觉得这本书最有价值的地方
不是教你怎么快速自负
而是他把自己的交易生活细节
实战经验
还有一路走来形成的交易观
摊开来给你看
书的版税他捐给了儿童技家庭辅助基金会
前阵子他在台北国际会议中心办奖座
门票扣除成本后也捐出去
看得出来他很愿意回馈社会
这本书的核心主张其实很直接
交易没有捷径
只有努力
这本书想回答的问题
大概可以整理成三个方向
首先
为什么多数人交易会输
作者的看法是
问题不完全在市场
而在于我们对交易的认知
很多人把交易当赌博
当赛车游戏
期望靠一次压力就翻身
却忽略交易其实是一门
需要系统化学习的专业技能
再来
真正的职业交易到底在做什么
职业交易员每天的工作
包含市场研究
策略测试
风险管理
交易执行
还有最重要的持续检讨
这是一份需要高度纪律与专注的工作
接着怎么把运气变成可复制的希望值
也就是透过建立交易系统
记录每一笔交易
分析数据与模式
把我栏的成功
逐步转化成可预测可验证的优势
关键在于找到正期望值的策略
然后持续执行
所以作者要我们记住的不是猜对方向
而是用纪律与检讨
把期望值做大
把风险做小
作者很强调的一句话是
教育是工作
不只是兴趣
教育是一份高复杂度的专业工作
从市场研究
策略开发
试担验证
到纪律执行
每日复盘
每个环节都需要专业的知识与技能
他也提醒要对损一保持平淡
因为赚赔只是工作结果的回馈
不应该变成情绪来源
太兴奋或太沮丧
都会影响下一次决策的品质
竞争优势来自投入强度加上持续年限
市场中没有天才
只有愿一日付一日投入
持续精进的专业人士
作者也分享自己早期会大量阅读投资相关书籍
包括会计
财务理论这些基础
教育生活中也持续阅读来理解别人的思维模式
换句话说
我们不是在跟市场比聪明而是在跟自己的贪婪情绪侥幸比耐力接下来进到本书核心的框架之一交易的数学作者说要盯期望值不要盯单笔结果
他的概念是
长期总损益大概等于
交易次数乘上期望值
而期望值
简单讲就是胜率成上平均获利
再减掉败率成上平均亏损
所以我们要做的不是追求每一笔都赢
也不是把胜率当作唯一指标
而是要做到输的时候小输
赢的时候大赢
建立高赚赔比的交易系统
他举了两个例子很清楚
策略一
胜率70%
平均获利一元
但平均亏损五元
期望值四负的
长期必然亏损
策略二
胜率只有40%
平均获利五元
平均亏损一元
期望值四正的
长期反而人获利
这也点出很多人的盲点
我们可能一直在追求赢的次数
但真正决定能不能长期活下来的
次数的大小和赢的幅度
作者也强调要做检讨
也就是复盘
检讨不是找理由
而是找可修正的动作
为什么检讨这么重要
因为交易做到最后
你会发现自己不是在研究市场
而是在研究自己
市场的规律可能会变
但人性的弱点却经年一致
所以你必须从对账单
成交明细里面
挖出自己的心魔与漏洞
每一笔亏损背后
其实都藏着一个可以改进的行为模式
检讨的核心目标包括
找出重复出现的错误模式
抓到违反纪律的时刻
分析情绪对决策的影响
验证策略是否有效
最后建立你自己的交易规则
作者也整理了一套七大检讨
当成每天的复盘清单
哪些交易是赚钱的
哪些该大赚却只有小赚
哪些不守纪律却赚到
提醒自己那可能只是运气
哪些交易是赔钱的
哪些不该赔却赔了
哪些应该小赔却大赔
哪些符合策略却能赔钱
这时候要想是策略需要微调
还是你必须接受正常波动
检讨的目的就是把错误变成规则
每一次复盘
都是在为你的交易系统
多加一条防护网
再来是风险报酬思维
作者说要找不对等的机会
核心是风险有限
报酬无穷
优秀的交易者
不是靠提高风险去追更高报酬
而是在不提高风险的前提下
设法拉大赚赔比
重点不在预测市场会涨或跌
而在于当你错的时候
能不能立刻止损
用这种思维交易
就不会执着每一次都要赢
而是会更在意输的时候输得起
赢的时候尽量放大
这就是职业交易人和赌徒的根本差异作者也重新定义技术分析他说技术分析不是算命而是读市场的共识很多人把技术分析当成预测未来的水晶球
期待指标告诉你明天涨跌
但作者认为正确的用法是
它不是用来预测
而是用来记录走势
辨识市场共识与节奏
不是问我希望什么
而是问市场现在同意什么
当你看到一个技术形态
真正有价值的不是它会不会涨
而是多数人看到这个形态会怎么做
因为你读的是市场参与者的集体行为
接着谈停损
作者的重点很清楚
停损不是看亏损几个百分比
而是看进场理由是否消失
停损是策略的一部分
不是失败的证明
他整理了几种常见情境
进场依据不成立
技术形态被破坏或基本面罗机变了
就该出场不论盈亏
走势发展不如预期
价格没有照预期方向移动或速度太慢
代表市场不认同你的判断
风险升高超出原本设计
像波动加剧
流动性降低或其他因素让风险超标
就应主动减仓或退出
很多人把停损机械化成跌破10%就出场
但作者提醒
真正的停损应该基于逻辑
而不是基于价格
进场理由消失
不管赚赔都该出场
反过来
如果理由依然成立
即使暂时亏损也不必恐慌
他也谈到工具与策略的演进
像选择权
股票期货
还有台股进入主笔戳合之后
交易节奏更接近期货
对他擅长的短线节奏更有利
作者的结论是
没有最好的工具
只有最适合当下情境的工具
策略不是信仰
而是理性的选择
另外
作者也提到利用规则与资讯差异
去寻找只有利多
没有利空的局
做法包括关注全子股
因为他会牵动大盘气氛与结算
也会观察政经事件与产业展会
因为这些资讯容易创造市场预期差
海外市场则看重要数据公布
像就业数据
人准会决议
不是靠消息本身赚钱
而是靠欲欺差与事前布局赚钱
当所有人都知道某个消息时
它通常已经没有价值了
你要做的是更早看到
更早准备
更早行动
作者还把交易者分成八个阶段
并强调年资不是开户多久
而是你累积了多少真实决策量
每天交易的人
三个月的经验
可能胜过三年偶尔操作的人
从初学摸索
动物
专业化
到系统化
稳定化
低情绪波动
交易融入生活
其实是在说你要逐步把交易从情绪游戏变成规则工作最后回到一种更稳定更平衡的状态对新手的建议很实际先活下来
再谈变强
先累基本金
从最小单位练习
先练动作再练规模
不追求高胜率
而是追求高赚赔比
也别听失败者的结论
要向有对账单
方法可验证的人学习
至于当中
他把它视为训练场
可以在等期大量角色中
快速造建情绪与纪律问题
但当初是否适合每个人
当然也见能见智
因为交易成本
手续费都要一并考量
最后是关于主力的迷思
把赔钱怪主力
是放弃检讨
市场确实有大资金
但他们同样受限于流动性
成本与风险
真正的大资金无瑕
针对散户小而上户
他们更在意的是趋势
资金流向与风控
而不是所谓收割散户
真正能改善的只有自己
你能控制的只有四件事
纪律 策略 心态 检讨
市场不欠我们一次反弹
怪主力之前
先检讨为什么自己没有按照停损规则出场
承认错误 承担责任
是走向职业交易的第一步
据人思维这本书
我觉得可以浓缩成三句话
把交易当工作
用投入与纪律换取长期优势
不是凭感觉 而是靠系统
用期望值思考
别迷信单笔结果
关注长期统计优势
而不是一时输赢
用检讨变强
每天把错误变成规则
持续精进
永不停止学习
交易的本质是一场跟自己的持久战
市场会不断测试你的纪律
耐心与决心
唯有建立正确的思维框架
并透过日复一日的刻意练习
才有机会在这个竞技场中长期生存
最后补充一下
聚人节代表的是偏高频
偏短线的交易风格
近期跟周冠兰教授的讨论
也让短线和长线再次被拿到台面上
我自己也会想到另一种相对的风格
像之前我介绍过林茂商老师的
我的职业是股东跟用心预不交易
更强调长线
跟随公司成长的思维
其实市场本来就有不同的交易风格
形态与思维
没有一种方式能适用所有人
看剧人思维
我会把它当成再看一部电影
你可以从电影里看到一个交易者的生活细节与实战经验
但看完不一定要过成电影主角那样的人生
我们最终还是要选择适合自己的路
如果你喜欢今天这集
欢迎订阅独跑自由
也可以到方格子搜寻独跑自由
看文字版的读书笔记
我是独跑哥
谢谢你的收看
我们下次见